madame la Première ministre monsieur le
Président chers collègues nous sommes
profondément touchés par le drame que
subit le peuple ukrainien c'est pourquoi
nous avons toujours condamné l'invasion
du territoire souverain de l'Ukraine et
appelé au rétablissement des principes
du droit international piétinés depuis
bien trop d'années par ceux qui
devraient les défendre cette guerre
européenne fratricide a vu naître une
remarquable mobilisation cherchant à
atténuer la souffrance de ceux qui
subissent cette guerre cette
mobilisation est le témoignage de notre
identité
car elle ne sait pas seulement faite par
l'action des nations mais également par
des initiatives locales rassemblant dans
un même élan les peuples et leurs corps
politique l'accueil des réfugiés le
soutien matériel nécessaire à un peuple
souffrant du froid et de la fin est
admirable et si nous comprenons la
politique de livraison d'armes
défensives qui rejoint cette volonté de
défendre la souveraineté et l'intégrité
territoriale des nations il est légitime
de s'interroger sur une poursuite de
l'escalade dont l'issue nous est inconnu
la poursuite de cette guerre n'est pas
seulement un drame humain mais risque de
renverser définitivement l'équilibre du
monde la victoire militaire de la Russie
lancerait un signal dramatique à ceux
qui demain pensent pouvoir régler leur
conflit territoriaux par la force la
livraison au compte-goutte d'armement
offensif signait elle probablement une
guerre de Cent Ans un engagement total
de l'OTAN seule hypothèse permettant
véritablement d'envisager une victoire
de l'Ukraine conduirait à une troisième
guerre mondiale
sans du conflit
défendre la paix ils seront retournés à
l'application de la loi du plus fort à
niant ainsi la souveraineté des peuples
et l'espoir de justice internationale
c'est pourquoi nous soutenons les
actions diplomatiques du gouvernement en
faveur de la paix la stabilité
géopolitique manque d'iale conséquences
des choix de la Russie nous obligent à
une grande prudence ne mes estimons pas
les nouvelles alliances de la Russie qui
séparait de l'Europe est devenu un
partenaire privilégié de l'un des de la
Chine alors que la paix a disparu des
consciences il est nécessaire de
commencer dès aujourd'hui son
édification et c'est pourquoi madame la
Première ministre je vous demande
solennellement si le président peut
faire entendre au monde qu'un espoir
demeure en organisant avec l'ensemble
des parties une grande conférence pour
la paix
je vous remercie